i have a penis i'll be the cat man hello
everybody my name is margaret and
welcome to speedrunners with jack wade
and bob
top of the mornings my name is
jacksepticeye and welcome to
speedrunners
jack bob mark and me
girl here and welcome to speedrunners
with sally jacksept
me and lord minnie we're ready all right
ready
we gotta be fair about this all right
who's gonna do the countdown someone
official someone
i'm not losing oh i'm losing losing
weight oh thanks you're welcome i
cleared all those for you because i love
you
yeah duh it's the first time anyone said
that oh oh no
oh no crap you suck i know i do i'm the
worst
i'm literally the worst oh god
mark you are such a douchebag
try hard mode right now oh god oh no i
made a mistake i made a horrible mistake
i made a horrible mistake i needed to
report my decision no
against a bunch of people and i don't
want to take it anymore oh god i'm so
slow
you're not that slow you're i'm pretty
okay i'm waiting i'm waiting i'm waiting
by the way i'm waiting i'm waiting i'm
being polite wait how do you how do you
boost
you uh right trigger that's how you
boost see was that something
people were
oh this is such an even match we're
doing so good guys you guys are the best
oh
oh is that bob there's bob bob's here
bob
bob's here what the hell he just here is
wait bob are you in here i don't see you
i'm i'm spectating
really when you guys when you guys die i
think i'm about to rejoin the game
well we're not in a game we're not in a
game yeah i'm expected oh
you're watching us play from before no
i was spectating other people
are you guys going the wrong way
that was really bad oh god bobby you
want a boost
bob you guys no no no i didn't mean to
do you slowed me down and didn't like
yes yes
get him you got him jackie
i'm fully erect right now oh really i'm
only half i got a half chub going why me
now jack's the one you hate right
because he's in the league
i really don't know how you hit every
box that was good oh i got this
i got this jacket oh my god one more win
everyone was like spazzing out over
there go go
go boost boost boost get away oh yes
yes turn around clock
yes bomb come on come on
vomit yes yes
part of his game there but if this
spikes bob just over time
neither i'm gonna get caught on the
spikes there he's bigger
wait how did that just happen i don't
know
oh no oh god okay
wait wait are you guys going root for me
now you guys are rooting for me
all right all right come on mark come on
mark i know you know
get them marketed for real like mlg for
realness
because i totally wasn't trying before
oh gosh give me something good correct
hello
okay okay
goddammit good lord i think we need a
minute to recover
i have so many tears in my eyes right
now i can't actually
see oh no
did you see this do you see this
properly
oh god i almost just fell out of my
chair
legitimately wait it's that you said
nothing about it it's just you blindly
rain
just nonsense you went the wrong way
that was the
that was possibly the most amazing thing
that's ever happened since we've played
games
together anyway so everyone besides
weight is improving in this game so
wait you've won once i won once okay
that did not work
go jack go yeah go jacob
jack oh
man that was the slowest death ever
just finished me up i expected to die
quicker than that
so i expected to win quicker than that
yeah there you go right there right
there you use it use it
it's okay it's all right it's okay it's
all right okay you can go away
just get ahead of him yeah get him late
watch out for the spikes okay
spicer use it now we're gonna use it use
it use it use it use it
oh i got your back dude why are you
teaming up against me
are you not on purpose
oh fine mark what no i thought
no oh no oh get ready for it oh
i did it i did it feels good in my nips
bob win this one
win this one come on bob you got this i
just need to get past him
you don't have to if you don't feel like
it wait win this one you gotta go
aggressive and get the power up it did
not pay off
oh
where's the goddamn grapples
okay
oh
won every one of them i'm gonna like
pass out after this
hey the vip lounge is up there oh oh oh
no
oh
oh you kidding me
jack is pulling ahead far in the lead
but bob is still in this race he's got
speed on his side until he hits
every every possible box
just think of how good he would do if he
didn't hit all the boxes
imagine imagine the skill hidden behind
that
terrible society
oh
oh you can't touch me right now uh i
could touch you
wade is in the lead wade
but that won't be enough to beat the
markiplier
oh the screen is getting smaller
as smoke takes the lead oh but he hits a
few points
is that a shortcut to where i'm going
because it better not be no no no oh
see you guys
friend bob sprint use your sprint get
rid of him
okay you didn't even need to do much
okay okay that no no
i missed that as well yes i'm missing
okay
it all started it all started because
mark let me win the first round
yeah i did i let you win he just like
stopped and then i stole it from you
that's totally yeah i let you win that's
right
yeah thanks so much for watching this
was probably the most fun we've had
recording in
a long time and there was so much stuff
we played for well over an
hour and it was impossible to cut it
down into just one episode on my channel
so they're all uploading their owns wade
bob and jack over here you can check out
their channels
they may have uncut portions they may
have multiple episodes
they may have just stuff that wasn't
included in mine so please go check them
out
they're all awesome it was all hilarious
the entire time we played and if you
want to play speedrunners for yourself
there's a link down in the description
below i highly recommend it get some
friends together or just play online
with other people
it's amazing so thanks again everybody
for watching
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
clickity-click click click here there
awesome
clicky here here here here here here
any one of these options are good please
click here now please
please get any kind of clack clickity
clag in the clock
you